welcome back to new rock stars i'm
whitney van laningham but just for today
you can call me scarlet witt and after
my 10 000th viewing of the multiverse of
madness trailer i can't get the image of
wanda standing over scarlet witch wanda
back in the westview house out of my
brain hole i've been racking my mind
with the age-old question which which is
which scarlet witch i think i finally
figured out what's really going on in
this scene it's pretty clear at this
point that the multiverse of madness
will incorporate the house of m's
storyline from the comics so today i'm
gonna break down exactly how these two
wandas could be the key to bringing
mutants into the mcu with a twist
it's a petsy twist man the trailer
brings us back to the house in west view
just as it was in episode 789 of one
division but instead of the perfectly
lived-in modern family-esque home she
shared with vision and their children we
see that the living room has been
destroyed almost as if this barefoot
wanda battled her scarlet witch
variation moments before the clip we see
in the trailer when we last saw wanda
maximoff she was hanging out at a cabin
in the mountains brewing tea while
simultaneously astral projecting her
scarlet witch form something that no
other sorcerer in the mcu has the
ability to do scarlet witch is reading
through the darkhold possibly searching
for her children outside the scope of
the mcu's reality she suddenly hears her
sons billy and tommy crying out for help
and her red spell flashes across the
screen before cutting to black now that
she's returned to the west view house it
seems that she's retracing her steps and
once again failing to assuage her grief
wanda wants more than anything for her
immense emotional suffering to end to be
reunited with her children or even
another form of vision someday and i
know we've all heard the line a thousand
times but what is that grief if not
wanda's love for her family persevering
at the end of the day finding tommy and
billy is her deepest desire one that
she'll stop at nothing to achieve we
later see wanda in the trailer covered
in blood and the camera zooms in to show
us a reflection in her pupils that seems
to show two holding cells just like the
ones she and her twin pietro were kept
in when they were being experimented on
we see similar cells and other imagery
from the trailer which we suspect to be
located at illuminati headquarters and
my guess is that these detention centers
are holding wanda's children in order to
get wanda to turn herself in but why are
they being held by the illuminati could
the members of the illuminati know
something about wanda's multiversal
history that we don't knowing that
patrick stewart is reprising his role as
professor x this could all be a lead-up
to the events of house of m entering the
mcu when he tells doctor strange that
it's time to tell him the truth eric
theorized in his multiverse of madness
breakdown that the truth he's about to
spill is that the mcu is currently
living in a post house of m reality and
that our little slice of the multiverse
has been gaslit into believing that
mutants don't exist to explain let me
quickly give you the lowdown on house of
m in the comics wanda chaotically resets
reality in an attempt to create a life
with her two children and creates a
house of m universe where superheroes
dominate society the heroes regain their
memories and confront wanda who declares
no more mutants erasing vast amounts of
mutants from reality in the mcu this
could explain why up until now no
mutants have existed we've all been
gaslit into thinking that they never
existed in this history but who spoke no
more mutants into existence that's where
these two wandas come in what if
barefoot wanda is actually the original
wanda the wanda from a past marvel
universe that had mutants in it who at
the end of a past house of m crisis
declared the words no more mutants
giving us our current avengers led mcu
this professor x might know what wanda
is capable of and the truth about our
reality's past and he likely knows that
holding wanda's kids just out of her
reach is the best way to lure her in for
capture this would make arwanda a
projection of the original where
wikifeet wanda is dark and bitter
arwanda is more grief-stricken and
empathetic and if the mcu really is a
post-house of m reality arwanda is gonna
have to fight back against her
alternative self gaslighting her and the
rest of the multiverse in order to
restore reality to a world where humans
avengers and mutants coexist in honor of
one of the most anticipated movies of
the year our friends at the epic hero
shop just released three new batman
themed shirts and two sock designs they
normally release new merch timed with
the release of the movie your show
they're inspired by but they're dropping
this batman merch early so you can have
it in time for opening night just
picture it you're in line to buy popcorn
and you get a knowing nod from the guy
working the register he leans in and
whispers hi i'm eric voss and now you've
just made a cool new best friend who can
slip you some free junior mints
our merch partners at epic hero shop
have all kinds of other cool designs
including two new shirts inspired by new
rockstar's favorite memed out villain
mephisto epic hero has all kinds of cool
merch inspired by all of your favorite
properties and they're always on top of
the latest trends bubbling out of the
stuff we're all into at the moment
they've got a trusted bro moving company
shirt that would look great paired with
a new rockstar zip up fleece sign up for
their newsletter at the bottom of their
website to get notified about the latest
merch drops and check out all of their
incredible products at epic heroshop.com
be your own hero wanda may have used her
powers alone to white mutants from the
mcu like she does in the comics or maybe
she used the runes of cough call like
doctor strange did in no way home
perhaps the runes were already in play
within the mcu before doctor strange
even cast that botched spell for peter
and casting it again badly on such a
wide scale broke the multiverse it's
possible that mutants like professor x
are able to travel to the mcu through
one of the cracks in reality now because
wanda's initial spell was broken in the
chaos the wanda that attacks the
illuminati hq is plainclothes barefoot
wanda she's the one that has history
with professor x and the illuminati you
can see that she's covered in blood with
inky spots on her clothing which could
mean that she's coming here after her
fight with scarlet witch wanda in the
west view house perhaps scarlet witch
was able to tell her the location of
tommy and billy that she found in the
dark hold and is defeated by
plainclothes wanda who then uses the
information to break her kids out of
those cells this may mean that
plainclothes wanda executes arwanda or
at least attempts to we see her gently
reach out and touch scarlet witch's face
in the trailer mirroring the way that
arwanda placed her hand on vision's
cheek moments before killing him in
infinity war professor x is clearly
aware and afraid of this dark version of
wanda which makes me wary of her too we
also know that wanda is one of the very
few nexus beings in the multiverse
confirmation of her status appeared in
that commercial for nexus
antidepressants from one division and
with the ability to also interact with
other versions of herself we know that
anything she does to affect reality will
also affect both versions of her doctor
strange very well could be looking for
her help to fix the multiverse as he
says in the trailer but he might also
simultaneously be searching for a way to
fix the multiverse in order to keep her
from being killed by the illuminati in
the comics professor x and the mutants
vote to execute wanda for her crimes
against the multiverse but strange is
the one who begs the others to let him
try to talk to her first he's able to
find her in the astral plane where she's
built a reality for herself that
includes tommy and billy and
communicates with her to get information
that might help save their reality as we
learned in the trailer breakdown the
orchard where strange meets wanda
doesn't really exist at least not in our
plane of reality the scene where he
visits her in that tree-filled pasture
could very well be taking place in the
astral plane where their projected
energy is able to communicate if strange
is able to get information from wanda in
the astral plane they could work
together to fight against the
illuminati's plan to keep the multiverse
segregated as it has been in order to
reunite with her children wanda will
have to break down their barriers to
other realities in doing so i believe
that we could finally see her reverse
the events of house of m declaring no
more madness this time around in order
to merge the multiverse into one reality
where the x-men the fantastic four my
boy deadpool and wanda's mutant sons now
co-exist in a wreck condom cu this could
be a really cool twist ending to house
of m finally bringing feige's promises
to open up the multiverse as the next
evolutionary step to fruition follow my
wanda variant scarlett wit on instagram
and twitter at whitney puppy follow new
rockstars and subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you